welcome back for seniors having trouble
paying their power bill there is help
angel williams with envy energy the
sponsors of this next segment has the
solution welcome to the show thank you
so you have some expos coming up to help
out the seniors tell us more about these
expos we do we have our first of four
senior energy assistance expos we kick
off tomorrow at the orleans from 8 a.m
to 12 p.m and then we're back at it
thursday and then tuesday and thursday
of next week at three other locations so
seniors what kind of assistance can they
can they get when they come out there
our customers that are age 62 and over
can income qualify for up to three
hundred dollars in assistance that's a
payment off their energy bill what do
they have to bring anything out there
when they come see you guys tomorrow i
do just need to bring a form of id
something that shows your income
qualification okay and if you have your
bill with you that's helpful too but we
can also look you up by your id you can
pull everything up now we're talking
before we start here there's about the
power shift and ways for seniors but
it's actually ways for everyone to cut
back on their power bill what are some
of the power shift options that you
recommend we love having these in-person
expos because it allows us to bring our
products and services directly to our
customers so you mentioned powershift
it's our energy efficiency program it's
great ways for customers to save money
everything from our free in-home
assessments online energy assessments
we've got our smart thermostats we've
got equal pay a variety of free
appliance programs for income qualified
seniors so lots of opportunities for
folks to save energy save money okay can
we break some of them down the free home
that you guys come inside and kind of
look at the lay of the land maybe you
need a shade somewhere what do you guys
do when you come into the in-home
estimates yeah they'll do a full
inspection on your home they'll help you
identify ways to help save energy they
also bring out with them some energy
efficient lighting and leave that behind
some energy efficient plug strips
a variety of products to help you save
money along with the tips that they're
going to leave you with there's so many
different options to save money you guys
are fantastic now with the expos you
have other partners that are out there
that are also helping out seniors what
are some of the partners that are out
there we're excited to have southwest
gas with us and they'll also be
qualifying our seniors for their energy
share program assistance on their gas
bill and then we have a variety of
nonprofits that are there to serve
seniors these are folks that are
providing access and helping seniors
navigate resources like rental and
utility assistance nutritional
assistance programs home repair
healthcare needs they're helping seniors
navigate those so it's more than just
energy energy that's out there this is a
great thing for seniors but if they're
watching for some reason they can't get
out there to the expo maybe it's
difficult to get out there are there
other ways they can apply for the
assistance there is we have on our
website nvenergy.com
expo you'll see a variety of different
non-profit partners that help us get
that assistance out year round so if you
can't make it in person please visit one
of those nonprofit partners and they'll
get you connected before we wrap it up
here you and i were talking before we
started there's one trick to cooling off
your house and that's the ceiling fan
indeed if you haven't you should run it
and you're saying though so this time
here in the summer time you want that
air you want the fan blowing the air
down definitely yeah and set your
thermostat at 79 78 helps keep it
running efficient i know that may seem
warm but it helps you save money in the
long run i love it that's this is all
about thank you so much angel we
appreciate it thanks again to nb energy
for sponsoring this segment for more
information about the senior energy
assistance expos visit nnb energy dot
com forward slash expo las vegas now we
will be
you